hier soir au théâtre du gymnase à
marseille
grande première de music hall et en même
temps affaire de famille viendra viendra
il faut que s'achève cette entité cri
d'amour
non
franck fernandel vedette américaine de
ce spectacle du gymnase achève son tour
de chant mais déjà déjà dans cette love
de la tête d'affiché fernandel lui
s'apprête et quelques années après le
départ de fernandel au tour de chant
cette l'ange votre même vous rappeler
quelque chose non cette loge me rappelle
beaucoup de souvenirs parce que
n'oublions pas que j'ai fait une reprise
d'ignace il ya 27 ans ici au théâtre du
gymnase
frank était né trois ans avant 1945 et
naturel membres
j'ai le souvenir et de la création et de
la reprise
ce personnage digne est ce qu a fait un
peu le tour du monde
mais dans ce même 27 ans après un tour
de chant ou une opérette on peut se
demander si fernandel retrouvant une
love indien un public éprouve le trac
mathilde albors jamais d'éprouver le
fera que non je ne suis pas un tracker
mafieux on l'a toujours malgré tout le
soir d'une première un petit pincement
au coeur parce que naturellement on ne
sait pas comment va être accueilli ce
nouveau tour
en deux ans la mère et l'enfant sont
vite arrivés à s'entendre
mais pour toi évidemment j'ai fini par
me rien comprendre
quand legault scribe et baie comeau
elle répond pour qu'il se taise à ces
taureaux que tu fais
miami un poupon et puis d'autres os au
coq ou bien si j'en avais fait autant
qu'en pour l'argent des fois elle
m'accroche
si j'avais dit jouer dead à longchamp
perdus sous a plus rien à mon poste
entre nous pour s'expliquer c'est un
petit peu limité capa quoi sans raconter
bien longue
j'ai reçu tout on ya mis un petit bouton
c'est une drôle de conversation
et bien c'est moi j'en avais fait autant
on serait tous gaga de plus lente
oui